uh let's bring a story that takes us a
little bit away from today's gloom
a student who couldn't afford to play
for university has been gifted
23 000 pounds and by an unlikely donor
this is the story of victoria mario
who got the surprise really of a
lifetime to discover that the pop star
taylor swift
had donated to her gofundme page giving
her the remainder of the money
she needed to hit her target it now
means she can accept her place at the
university of warwick
to study mathematics in september
delighted to say vitoria joins us now
to tell us about how this has come come
about victoria
welcome to you thanks so much for
joining us um
tell us how all this came about i mean
this is an extraordinary twist really i
mean
how on earth did she find out
find out i don't know i actually don't
know
i still asked that myself how did you
reach out to her because
i have no idea personally i have no idea
what was the situation you found
yourself here i mean let's just take a
whine back a little bit you wanted to do
mathematics
at warwick you obviously got the grades
to go there
uh as you know thankfully many people
did this year um
and what was your financial situation
why were you how were you struggling
could you not could you not get a loan
for instance
um yes i've i wasn't eligible for my
maintenance loans provided by the
government
because i've not been here for five
years yet so they wouldn't be giving it
to me
so i had to get sponsorship or
fundraise money just kind of just get
the money somewhere else basically yeah
and whose idea was the go was was was it
your idea to set up the go fund page
because
that's the way to go isn't it really
yeah i really had an idea beforehand but
then i kind of just
didn't pay much attention to it but then
someone at church talked to me saying
create a gofundme page like you have
nothing to lose and i did it
yeah how true that turned out to be has
she been in touch with you directly
taylor swift no no no
no she hasn't yeah so we we are
absolutely sure
it's heard i mean it's a substantial
donation how much are we sort of 23 000
pounds
yes yes so but we're absolutely certain
the money is from her there's no
question it's definitely from taylor
swift
that's the question personally to be
honest i don't know
i feel like it's very likely that is her
because i wouldn't
believe that someone considers us norm
if that makes sense will donate that
amount of money
to a cause like mine uh but personally
at to be honest i don't know but i
believe
yeah i believe it's her yeah i mean
why do you think she's singled you out i
mean maybe she's doing this
to lots of people helping out people all
over the world she's got the money
she's got the money to do it right so so
why not
um i think i asked myself i don't know
why me
of course in the message she said she
was touched by my story and my
dedication
and my effort that i've been having
throughout these whole years
i feel like that's what touched it the
most i think was my story personally
yeah and victoria to be clear if this
money hadn't been raised
what was your alternative would it you
know you just wouldn't have gone to
warwick
um i would but i'll be struggling
definitely financially speaking
i'll have to get a job and kind of
manage it with my um schedule
even though it would be very full
because of course maps he requires
a lot of effort but i would definitely
be struggling
i'm not going to deny that yeah yeah i i
can hear
the grinding of teeth from some of our
viewers thinking well you know
you can always wash up plates or
whatever but you're doing a you know
you're doing a maths degree you
it's more than the the obligatory sort
of half a dozen lecturers
lectures for people doing english or
something he says speaking from personal
experience
and if you could send her a message what
would it be
i'll just say first of all a big thank
you
thank you and that would even call her
blessing because that's what i feel it
was like it was a blessing
out of the blue a blessing i definitely
need it
and i just even i wish that god pays you
10 times more
definitely yeah and let's assume you get
through the course
uh you you come away with a maths degree
um
what do you want to do with your maths
degree have you got a career in mind yet
victoria is it too soon to know that
sort of thing did you know that sort of
thing
i'm quite unsure but i feel like i would
pursue your occurring technology
definitely i feel like i see myself yeah
working in the technology
well you should try and have a word with
taylor swift she might be able to open
up some doors for you who knows
victoria mario very lovely to talk to
you and uh good luck with your studies
in warwick thanks a lot thank you
thank you so much